hey what's up it's anthony from  philadrist and today we're going to be  talking about the product of the week  and this week's product is the viral  transport medium also known as the vtm  this one's got the neutralizing buffer  vtms are the go-to method for safely  transporting your clinically collected  samples that's right these samples are  gonna go safely from your nose straight  to the thermocycler  this bad boy will deactivate and  preserve your sample specimens for up to  20 days  our kits include 100 btms with  neutralizing buffer solutions and  biohazard bags included we're running a  very limited time offer on these select  btm kids so make sure to pick some up at  filtrust.com before they're gone see you  next week